le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais la Réunion
détient une richesse unique avec des
espèces protégées c'est un réel atout
pour la Réunion d'avoir su conserver
autant de richesses qui font d'elle un
territoire d'exception une île qui
défend son identité et préserve son
patrimoine les weekends nature ont été
mises en place par le Conseil général
depuis 10 ans pour une découverte au
cœur de Lille et notamment des espaces
naturels sensibles propriétés de la
collectivité quelles sont les
différentes espèces de l'île quelles
actions mènent le Conseil Général pour
conserver la nature de notre île les
week-ends
avec près de 95 000 hectares le Conseil
Général et le premier propriétaire
forestier de l'île et principal
financeur avec l'Europe des programmes
de travaux de mise en œuvre par l'Office
National des Forêts l'ONF ces actions
sont donc primordiales afin de préserver
la biodiversité de protéger les milieux
des plantes invasives du défrichement et
de la pression urbaine valoriser les
espaces naturels pour permettre
l'accueil du public fait partie de ces
attributions et c'est une importante
source d'emplois pérenne et d'insertion
proposée dans ce secteur ainsi qu'un
développement économique non négligeable
riche en espèces endémiques la Réunion
dévoile ses secrets à travers ses
visites guidées Jocelyn CUS gestionnaire
en ens nous emmène à Cap Blanc pour une
visite guidée des plus passionnantes
alors ici nous trouvons sur l'espace
naturel sensible de l'Angevin donc une
des particularités de cet espace naturel
c'est que c'est un ens rivière donc qui
découle des affluents de la rivière
Langevin le but cette visite bien sûr
c'est de découvrir une diversité
d'espèces indigènes endémique et
exotique que ce soit au niveau de la
faune ou de la flore il faut savoir qu'à
la réunion à la base c'est un volcan qui
sortit de la merde donc il y avait
aucune espèce végétale sur l'île il y a
des espèces qui sont arrivées
naturellement c'est à dire soit par les
courants marins les vents ou les oiseaux
ce qu'on appelle les espèces indigènes
donc on peut retrouver dans des îles
voisines des continents voisins qui sont
pas forcément propres à l'île de la
Réunion ensuite il y a certaines de ces
espèces indigènes qui soient pour des
raisons climatiques géologiques ou
pédologiques par rapport au sol qui se
sont spécifiés on dit qu'elles ont muté
sont devenu endémiques aller de la
Réunion donc là ce sont des espèces
pendant que sont devenus propres à chez
nous qui n'existent nulle part ailleurs
sur la planète et par la suite avec
l'arrivée de l'homme on a eu des espèces
exotiques sont toutes que l'homme a
apporté ces plantes exotiques là souvent
ben il y en a bon nombre d'entre elles
qui sont devenus envahissantes pas
toutes mais une bonne majorité là dans
une zone qui est principalement
recouverte d'espèces exotiques invasive
donc justement la jouvence de la baie
sourit alors ici nous sommes sur une
zone test sur laquelle on essaie de
faire de la restauration écologique
c'est-à-dire de remettre en valeur les
espèces indigènes et endémiques donc ça
fait quasiment 6 ans qu'on intervient
sur cette petite parcelle là sur
laquelle de manière manuelle on procède
à de l'arrachage systématique des
espèces exotiques invasives donc à
l'époque ce secteur là était recouvert
de galabert de choucas de goyavier donc
nous on a essayé de limiter l'expansion
de ces espèces là dans cette zone là on
a du bois de balai qu'on appelle aussi
bois de cerise marron on a du bois
d'oiseaux parce que les oiseaux sont
très friands de ces fruits on a des
cafés marrons on a des boîtes corail
tout un panel d'espèces qui petit à
petit se réapproprie le milieu donc là
on a un kilomètre 600 sur lequel on peut
pêcher la truite arc-en-ciel en
respectant bien sûr les périodes de
pêche les quotas donc les quantités ici
c'est 4 truites par jour par pêcheur et
la maille donc il y a une taille minimum
à respecter qui est actuellement de 20
cm alors il faut savoir qu'à l'époque
Cap Blanc était habité et cultivé les
gens vivaient dans ce secteur de manière
isolée un peu comme à Mafate donc les
gens vivaient ici en parfaite harmonie
avec la nature et un peu en autarcie
donc il cultivait un peu de tout le maïs
cambard chouchou là on a la culture on a
un pied de mûrier il y a des plantes
d'ornement des camélias les gens déjà
pour des raisons de sécurité sont partis
parce que le secteur était très soumis
aux inondations de terrain il y a eu des
familles qui ont été décimées suite à
des périodes de cycloniques notamment il
y a beaucoup d'anciens qui sont nés à
Cap Blanc et qui vivent maintenant à
grand galet mais ils ont quand même
gardé cette
cette tendance là venir sur Cap Blanc
toujours voir si il reste des vestiges
de chouchou de Camba qui était planté
justement à l'époque donc il y avait
encore tous ces murets en pierres sèches
qui témoignent des anciennes habitations
marine Richardson est conservatrice en
espace naturel sensible l'espace naturel
sensible des Hauts de la rivière
Langevin
suit 2007 le Conseil général a délégué à
la fédération départementale de pêche de
La Réunion la gestion de cette espace
naturel remarquable il y a un magnifique
parcours de pêche à la truite et le rôle
de la fédération et de son association
la mars c'est de mettre en oeuvre
l'entretien des sentiers l'entretien des
parcours et l'entretien des accès à la
rivière par les pêcheurs pour les
weekends nature et toutes les
informations sur le site du Conseil
Général et pour le reste de l'année il
suffit de contacter l'association des
rivières du Sud
certes les 16 espaces naturels sensibles
sont ouverts au public toute l'année
mais les week-ends
des randos familiales ou on prend le
temps de s'arrêter de faire des pauses
et de découvrir ce que la nature a à
nous offrir durant tout le mois
d'octobre mettez-vous au vert et vivez
des moments inoubliables avec des
visites guidées gratuites en vous
inscrivant sur le site du Conseil
Général retrouvez toutes les dates des
week-ends